ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE I'M
SPEAKING TO.
>> SOME GOOD NEWS.
MAX FOSTER, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME NOW, DR. JONATHAN
REINER, PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE
AND SURGERY AT GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY ALSO A CNN MEDICAL
ANALYST, AND DOCTOR, FIRST START
ON THE QUEEN TESTING POSITIVE.
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST CONCERN
RIGHT NOW BOTH FOR HER AND IN A
MICROSENSE AND MORE MACRO LEVEL,
OTHERS IN A SIMILAR-AGED
CATEGORY WHO TEST POSITIVE NOW?
>> PHIL, COVID KILLED THE
EARLIERLY.
LOOKING AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC, 75% OF ALL DEATHS IN
THE UNITED STATES HAVE COME IN
FOLKS OVER THE AGE OF 65.
LOOK AT THE GROUP OVER 75, THEY
COMPRISE ABOUT HALF OF ALL
DEATHS TO COVID IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THE QUEEN HAS BEEN VACCINATED,
AND THAT DRAMATICALLY REDUCES
HER RISK OF DIEING FROM THIS,
BUT SHE'S ALMOST 96 YEARS OLD
AND 96-YEAR-OLD PEOPLE HAVE VERY
LITTLE RESERVE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF DEATHS IN
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE QUEEN'S
POPULATION, IN PEOPLE OVER THE
AGE OF 65.
ABOUT 85% OF THE DEATHS OCCUR IN
OLDER PEOPLE.
IF I WAS TREATING THE QUEEN NOW,
I WOULD HAVE RAPIDLY
ADMINISTERED OR GUN TREATMENT
WITH PAXLOVID, WHICH IS THE
ORAL, VERY POTENT, VERY
EFFECTIVE ANTI-VIRAL REGIMEN AND
I ASSUME THE QUEEN HAS RECEIVED
THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON IS
EXPECTED TO END SELF-ISOLATION
RULES FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE COVID.
UNDER CURRENT REGULATIONS PEOPLE
WHO ARE TEST POSITIVE ARE BOUND
TO SYCE LAIT ISOLATE FIVE DAYS
AND TEST NEGATIVE TWICE BEFORE
ENDING ISOLATION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I THINK IN LONDON THE RATE
PER 100,000 POPULATION IS SOME
LIKE 60 CASES PER DAY PER
100,000 POPULATION, LOWER THAN
IT WAS A MONTH AGO.
MUCH LOWER.
STIG SIGNIFICANT.
STILL SIGNIFICANT.
THIS RACES THE OVERALL POINT
WHEN IT'S SAFE TO DROP OUR GART.
THINGS ARE GETTING MUCH BETTER,
POPULATION HERE AND IN THE
UNITED STATES, JUST ITCHING TO
DROP ALL PANDEMIC MITIGATION
MEASURES, THERE'S STILL
SIGNIFICANT VIRUS AROUND.
THE PEOPLE THAT WILL SUFFER FROM
ANY FURTHER SURGE ARE PEOPLE
LIKE THE QUEEN OF ENGLAND.
PEOPLE WHO ARE AT RISK.
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLD.
PEOPLE WHO ARE OTHERWISE
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED RECOVERING
FROM A SERIOUS ILLNESS.
WHICH IS WHY I AND, YOU KNOW,
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE URGED
AT LEAST, YOU KNOW, A VERY
MEASURED, CAREFUL, EVEN SLOWER
REDUCTION IN DROPPING MASKING,
PARTICULARLY IN PUBLIC, UNTIL
LEVELS OF THIS VIRUS ARE AT MUCH
LOWER LEVELS THAN THEY ARE NOW.
I THINK WE'LL BE THERE WITHIN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
BUT THIS IS JUST A VERY -- VIVID
EXAMPLE OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN
THE VIRUS CONTINUES TO CIRCULATE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
>> YEAH.
CERTAINLY IS.
BEFORE I LET YOU GO, I HAVE TO
ASK YOU ABOUT COMMENTS FROM ERIC
TRUMP ABOUT THE COVID VACCINE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WHAT IS YOUR OPINION IN
GENERAL ON THE VACCINATION
SITUATION?
>> PISSED OFF.
>> PISSED OFF?
>> YEAH.
NOT BECAUSE I'M AN ANTI-VAXXER.
I'M PISSED OFF BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A POLITICAL PARTY OF DEMOCRATS
GONE AROUND FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS YELLING, LIE BODY, MY
CHOICE, AS PERTAINED TO ABORTION
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, GUESS WHAT?
NO LONGER YOUR BODY, YOUR
CHOICE.
THE VACCINE TO ME REPRESENTS
SOMETHING MUCH GREATER THAN A
MEDICAL SHOT.
TO ME THE VACCINE REPRESENTS
LITERALLY RESTRICTING OF
FREEDOMS IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> RIGHT.
BUT IT'S ALSO MEDICAL SHOT, WHAT
IT ACTUALLY REPRESENTS.
I REMIND PEOPLE ERIC TRUMP'S
FATHER FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
VACCINATED.
HE MADE THAT CLEAR.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION, DOCTOR TO
ERIC TRUMP'S COMMENTS?
>> SOMETIMES IT'S BETTER TO KEEP
YOUR MOUTH SHUT THAT EXPOSE YOUR
IGNORANCE.
STRIPPING OF FREEDOMS.
RIGHT?
IT'S MISTER, MR. TRUMP'S FATHER
NOT JUST TAKES CREDIT FOR, FOR
THE VACCINE BASICALLY TAKES
CREDIT FOR ALMOST INVENTING THIS
VACCINE.
LOOK, IF YOU LOOK AT 11900.
A 48-YEAR LIFE EXPECTANCY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
NOW IT'S ALMOST 80 YEARS.
BROUGHT ABOUT MY MASSIVE
ADVANCES IN TREATMENT OF
INFECTION DISEASES AND
VACCINATIONS.
A CHILD BORN IN 1900 HAD ABOUT A
ONE IN FOUR CHANCE OF DIEING
BEFORE THEY TURNED 5.
NOW THAT'S 0.07%.
SO THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT ABOUT BY
VACCINES.
SO WHEN MR. TRUMP BASICALLY IS
ADVOCATING, IT'S A RETURN TO
MEDIEVAL TIMES.
MAKE AMERICA MEDIEVAL AGAIN.
IT'S REALLY UNBECOMING AND
NONSENSICAL.
AMERICANS LIVE TO ALMOST 80
YEARS OLD BECAUSE WE EMBRACE
SCIENCE NOT BECAUSE WE REFUSE
SCIENCE.
>> YEAH.
SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN FAIRLY
EFFECTIVE.
LOOK, THE DEBATE IDEOLOGICALLY
OV